did you have to audition for that show I
did not because I had auditioned
unsuccessfully for Wolf of Wall Street
ah so he had seen your work before
that's the one I was too old for is that
oh really was that the when when you
don't get a movie like Wolf of Wall
Street do you go to the theater and
watch it and say this is no I
watched it and I was like oh she's
perfect I thought she kicked so much ass
in that movie but don't you sort of as
an actress that's a that's a plum role
and you just kind of go oh what
could I have done differently I have
some to cut off emotionally the second I
don't get a role it's like dead to me
but Martin Scorsese it shows you though
he must have really liked your audition
cuz he put you in this other thing yeah
it was cool I it shows that like if you
don't get something job interview
whatever you do for a living like it
might lead to something else